comptez on va terminer avec ce très beau
travail vous avez fait danièle herry ben
sûr michel foucault dont une biographie
de michel foucault qui est mort hier
84,50 ya cinq ans est-ce que vous avez
bien connu
oui oui mais il est connu dans comme
gilles lapouge avec la quand je les
connais dans mes fonctions tout d'abord
dans mes fonctions journalistiques
je l'avais rencontrée en 79 3 pions nous
on est devenus amis et en famille je les
ai fait bien connu dans les cinq
dernières années de sa vie
et puis surtout vous connaissiez très
bien georges dumézil à qui vous avez
consacré un livre qui était sale et ses
faubourgs qui m'avait présenté oui c'est
ça et ça c'était un peu étonnant de
penser que du midi la voie ya une grande
différence d'âge entre eux était
vraiment ils étaient deux grandes amies
ah oui c'est une fin des gens m'ont dit
en lisant mon livre est ce que tu
n'exagère pas l'amitié entre d'homicide
et foucault et ça je fais je me souviens
très bien et d'avoir entendu foucault et
du midi le tout les deux dire que
vraiment il se voyait tout le temps ce
téléphone est sans arrêt pour chats et à
chaque étape cru c'est que j'ai commencé
ce livre dumézil m'a beaucoup donné de
renseignements est en effet à chaque
étape cruciale de sa carrière foucault a
été aidé par dumézil qui le qui était
une sorte d' ombre tutélaire qui le dira
il en apprend mille choses dans votre
votre livre et surtout sur les débuts de
michel foucault coup ne connais pas bien
et ce qui est curieux c'est que il était
professeur au collège de france
en filtrant philosophe beaucoup de
succès auprès des livres aux philosophes
de réputation internationale et en même
temps on peut dire qu'il a fini sa vie
comme d'autres la commence c'est à dire
qu'il était devenu depuis 68 69 un
militant gauchiste pétitionnaires
défilant dans la rue et cetera
et alors on pouvait penser qu'il avait
été un jeune homme turbulent or pas du
tout quand on arrive c'est vrai qu'on
enfin l'image de faim le foucault qu'on
connaît c'est le foucault gauchistes de
l'après-68 est en fête et enfin quand
vous dites que vous avez appris tout ça
moi j'ai appris aussi en faisant mon
enquête ce pour faire ce livre jallet de
surprises en surprises et en effet
foucault avant 68 a été un jeune homme
très sage
ensuite un étudiant très
vingt travailleurs et qui m'aiment
faisait rire ses camarades away un peu
parce que là je vous arrête c'est pas
tout à fait vrai vous montrer quand la
normale supérieure il est même assez
détesté de ses gongs ironique
oui oui les faits il est presque
unanimement détesté sauf de quelques
personnes avec qui il a des amitiés
passionnés et enfin c'est quelqu'un qui
suscitait fin dans ces années là le la
haine ou lou l'amitié pensionnés nous
montrer solitaire agressif suivi leur
wii wheel temps il fait une tentative de
suicide essentiellement en 48
mais il s'en doute il y en a eu d'autres
d'après ce que m'ont dit d'aimer - moins
sérieuses et puis en effet il était très
très isolée très très rares cas c'est
pourquoi je crois qu'il était très mal
dans sa peau ou simplement de le g10 un
père dont le génie sol
pourquoi parce qu'il se sentait à paris
s'il n'était pas à paris n'aurait pas
fait une oeuvre qu'il a fait
il est il ya aussi une raison au fait
qu'ils ont enfin moi je ne sais pas
quand mais ce défi on peut parler très
très honnêtement je crois que dans les
années 45 50 il devait très très très
difficile de vivre son homosexualité et
enfin vous avez reçue il ya quelques
mois dominique fernandez qui raconte sa
très très bien sûr puisqu'il avait à peu
près le même âge que foucault était à
normale sup presque en même temps et qui
raconte sa retraite très bien comment il
était vraiment épouvantablement
difficile de vivre son homosexualité
dans ses années d'enfance
il faut qu on a vécu ça dans la honte et
dans le temps la faute dans le drame et
les tentatives de suicide fin de la
tentative de suicide en tout cas le
médecin de l'école normale me l'a
expliqué comme ça sans vouloir me donner
de détails puisqu'il ya le secret
médical en face et l'explication qu'il
donne est toute sa vie foucault a été
j'avais dire torturé par par sa part le
la difficulté de vivre son homosexualité
et le foucault différents qu'on connaît
après 69 c'est aussi peut-être parce que
appartient 69 il était beaucoup plus
facile de oui mais ils changent entre ce
jeune homme un peu solitaire et agressif
et puis le
le militant gauchiste a faim il ya une
autre époque où vous nous montrez
presque un dandy quelqu'un qui un dandy
oui là il a une jaguar qui en suède il a
eu la gorge salade je publie la photo
d'ailleurs que j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
trouver mais j'ai réussi en fait
quelqu'un me la donner et parce que
j'avais du mal à croire à cette jaguar
et enfin la photo est stupéfiante qu'est
ce qu'on veut en effet une énorme jaguar
et un jour d'ailleurs il a un accident
avec georges dumézil qui le parce que
évidemment le salaire les routes étaient
glacées et mais georges dumézil dans le
fossé en voiture et ensuite ils se
retrouvent en france à clermont-ferrand
puisqu'il est nommé à clermont ferrand
comme professeur depuis que le jeu est
effectivement tout le monde l'a décrit
comme un dandy il était en en cap de
l'eau des verts avec un chapeau de loden
et vous avez même découvert autre chose
qui pue stupéfiants c'est son rôle
ben au ministère de l'éducation
nationale alors ça c'est une chose que
j'ignorais totalement et quand on m'a
dit ça j'avais du mal à le croire
et comme fin j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup
de mal à trouver ces documents c'est à
dire les procès verbaux de la commission
de réforme fouchet et foucault avait été
nommé par le ministre christian fouchet
parce que l'un des conseillers
techniques de christian schricke et le
ministre de l'éducation nationale du
général de gaulle dans les années au
début des années 60 et qui sera
d'ailleurs ministre de l'intérieur
pendant mai 68 christian fouchet demande
à michel foucault de participer à la
commission d'élaboration de la fin de la
réforme de l'enseignement supérieur et
foucault participe à toutes les
commissions copains que je cite les
procès verbaux et même fait écrit des
documents des textes préparatoires c'est
que ces travaux de commission sur la
réforme de la thèse la réforme de
l'agrégation et vers une participation
tout à fait
assidu ce qui est assez étonnant quand
on sait que là on a dit que la réforme
foucher avait été le déclencheur de mai
68 parce qu'il est important de savoir
que son père il est né à poitiers fukui
son père l'appelle chirurgien et un
grand chirurgien assez important parce
que la faille d'abord parce qu'il a fait
un livre sur sur l'aef qui s'appelle de
naissance de la clinique un livre sur la
médecine les le les catégories médical
de la médecine moderne l'institution
hospitalière que certains considèrent
comme pas moi mais que certains
considèrent que même ses plus beaux
livres de ses plus grands livres et
effectivement c'est une sorte de ce
livre il paraît en 1963 c'est à dire
quatre ans après la mort de son père et
on peut s'en vouloir me substituer à un
psychanalyste on peut dire qu'on a fait
c'est une manière peut-être de régler un
compte avec ce père qu'il je crois il
avait détesté pendant toute son
adolescence et nous voilà c'est une
chose assez étonnante et que dans la
famille les enfants porte toujours le
nom du papa de la famille foucault et
donc il s'appelle paul foucault et sa
mère qui ne vous qui ne voulez pas de
sang mêlé dans les prénoms lui avais
adjoint michel paul michel foucault et
il a renoncé à s'appeler paul foucault
et tous les documents de comptes de fin
de centre sur sa scolarité jusqu'à
normale sup porte le nom paul foucault
et puis un beau jour ça change et il
devient michel foucault ce qui est
étonnant c'est que après normal il y
avait quand même une très longue période
durant laquelle il n'est plus du tout en
france il est partout ici je parlais de
son ensemble est d'être une espèce de
fuite en exil volontaire il veut quitter
la france il part ensuite il part enfin
il est resté trois ans donc dans le dans
l'hiver d'uppsala dans la nuit du salat
parce qu'on se fait d'un nuit tombée à
deux heures de l'après midi
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles il
part d'ailleurs il va ensuite il des
goûts des lecteurs de français il va
ensuite à varsovie et à hambourg
et quand il rentre en france il n'a
qu'une envie c'est de repartir il
il est sur le point de partir à tokyo
pour diriger l'institut culturel
français
mais il reste en pour nous parce que il
a eu un conflit à l'université
clairement quel est le livre qui lui
apporte
on peut dire la renommée c'est les mots
et les choses restent ablement quand
même avant quand même si chaud lui c'est
lui moi n'est pas là renouvellement
s'est elle estime que l'excusé des
chances c'est vraiment leur nom à leurs
avants avant 65 ans lui même d'ailleurs
se plaindre a beaucoup parlé par après
dans les années 75 s'obtiendra beaucoup
de l'absence d'accueil qui avait été
fait à son premier enfant son premier
grand livre qui est l histoire de la
folie c'est sa thèse
et c'est vrai que s'il avait eu un
article de fernand braudel un article de
roland barthes un article de michel
saive ce qu'il ya des gens qui
aimeraient bien avoir un manque
d'accueil de sion mais c'est pas que la
renommée la grande renommée et la
renommée public c'est les mots et les
choses bizarres parce que c'est un livre
extrêmement difficile à dire le michel
foucault est brassée à fonctionner
c'était le 17 décembre 1976 il avait pas
voulu d'ailleurs parler les mamans les
200 livres l'ennemi était venu pour
parler d'un autre lit les dissidents sa
vie voilà des dissidents soviétiques et
voilà on va l'écouter pendant une minute
et demie c'était la fin de l'émission il
ya dix ans chez vous pour publier les
mots et les choses et il ya juste dix
ans et vous écriviez l'homme fanon pour
les visions c'est la fin l'homme n'est
pas le plus vieux problème ni le plus
constant qu'il soit posée au savoir
humain et ajouter un voilier vide en
tout la page nos fins l'homme est une
invention dont l'archéologie de notre
pensée montre aisément la date récente
et peut-être la fin prochaine
oui parce qu'il m'a semblé en effet que
le moment où l'homme avait commencé à
devenir un problème à la fois
philosophique mais également technique
politiques économiques cruciaux pour lui
même ce moment n'était pas aussi ancien
qu'on pouvait l'imaginer
bien sûr il ya des fameux les
traditionnelles questions que nous
connaissons si vous voulez moi je crois
qu'à partir d'un certain moment qu'on
peut se situer entre la fin du xvième
siècle et du début du 19e s'est passé un
phénomène important
même c'est que l'homme a cessé d'être
immédiatement dominé par les grandes
menaces de la mort c'est à dire par les
menaces des épidémies des familles des
formidables ravages de la mortalité
infantile et que l'homme en quelque
sorte disposer des sociétés humaines
je parle uniquement d'ailleurs de
l'occident mais c'est là où les choses
se sont noués que les sociétés
occidentales ont commencé à disposer
d'une espèce de marge de survie à partir
duquel l'homme est devenu relativement
disponible par rapport à ces urgences
fondamentalement assez grande menace de
la mort qui avait traversé ce d'histoire
jusque là et alors c'est à partir de ce
moment là qu'il a fallu en quelque sorte
à la fois utilisées et mettre en
question essayer de problématiser
l'homme en tant qu il pouvait être
disponible d'où la question qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on va en terre comment
l'appliquer appliquer cet individu bien
à la croissance des forces productives
comment les disciplines et comment
construire des grands corps politique et
des reins et je crois qu'on a eu un tout
une technologie de l'homme qui s'est
développée à partir de ce moment là qui
est la question de l'homme
est ce que cette question sera durera
autant que l'humanité peut être peut
être pas c'était une émission qui avait
été enregistré au louvre alors
d'inattendu didier eribon l'émission et
malheureusement elle se termine c'est
que on trouvera dans votre livre tous
les rapports parfois conflictuels avec
les grands votre grand de la pensée avec
sartre avec avec la cambe et yala
compris de debout sur la corde il a
accès
très influencé par là quand ils sont son
livre les mots et les choses et placé
sous l'invocation de lacan et par la
suite de dix ans après du zellige pour
lequel vous l'aviez invité en 76 c'est à
dire la volonté de sa de savoie est un
livre écrit presque entièrement contre
lacandons qu'il ya un basculement
si vous voulez de la pensée de fléaux
même avec ça avec sartre ou brillant 66
quand sortent les mots et les choses
sartre dit michel foucault c'est une
dernier barrage que la bourgeoisie érige
contre l'avancée du marxisme ce qui est
assez surprenant et cinquante trois ans
après des 69 y sont à la même tribune la
mutualité pourfendre le l'éruption de de
la police à vincennes et puis deux ans
après en 71 ils sont au coude à coude
dans les manifestations du avec aaron
avec aaron alors là j'ai la fille de
raymond aron a eu la gentillesse de me
donner là que je publie d'ailleurs le la
correspondance entre michel foucault et
raymond aron et qui est une
correspondance tout à fait surprenante
parce que on imaginait deux blocs de
haine entre ces deux hommes est en fait
raymond aron invite foucault à son
séminaire fou en 67 foucault il va tout
se passe très bien et le il semble même
que raymond aron et c'est depuis ce que
foucault il était candidat à la sorbonne
et ne peut pas être élu à la sorbonne il
ya un barrage et il semble même que
aaron était favorable lui à la
candidature de foucauld à la sorbonne il
va être un des rares avec que georges
canguilhem un livre bourré de
révélations vraiment pas seulement sur
la joue beaucoup mais si on le dirait
sur le mouvement intellectuel de depuis
depuis 30 ans